bonsoir junien ou double merci d'être
avec nous vous deviez à l'origine un
débattre voilà avec sa mine bola qui
avocats membres de l'association action
contre l'islamophobie mais finalement on
fera une interview en tout cas je vous
remercie d'être en direct avec nous des
fascistes dans nos amphis l'islamophobie
tu vois là ce qui était écrit clairement
jeudi dernier sur les affiches à
l'entrée du campus affiches sur
lesquelles on pouvait lire le nom de
dodo professeur jean michel blanquer qui
dénonce cet après midi des logiques de
délation public est ce que le ministre
de l'éducation raisons selon vous oui
bien sûr jean michel leblanc caire a
totalement raison
et je tiens à dire que l'islamophobie tu
dans notre pays c'est vrai
l'islamophobie peut tuer celles et ceux
qui sont accusés d' islamophobie
car aujourd'hui c'est le véritable
problème et moi je tiens vraiment à
m'insurger contre la récupération de ce
concept qui a été monté de toutes pièces
qui a été construit par les islamistes
l'islamophobie est un concept islamistes
pour empêcher toute critique toute
condamnation de l'islam du voile
islamique du burkini du halal dans les
cantines
c'est un concept islamiste est
aujourd'hui qui malheureusement s'est
développé dans la société française que
je sois à l'université via des syndicats
comme l'unef qui n'en est pas
malheureusement à son coup d'essai
puisque l'unef est sortie totalement on
peut dire du champ républicain depuis
quelques années est sorti du finalement
une idéologie de gauche qui était la
sienne pour passer à une de logis islamo
gauchiste que ce soit pour la promotion
du hidjab matin midi et soir pour la
promotion du racialisme est là pour ses
combats pour dénoncer et lens est
carrément les fatwas donc pour
l'islamophobie pour dénoncer ce qu on
appelle çà mau phobie
donc tout ça c'est extrêmement grave
c'est extrêmement grave et ça nécessite
des pouvoirs publics du ministère
évidemment de l'éducation nationale de
tous les responsables politiques une
réponse extrêmement fermes et
extrêmement fermes pour protéger d'une
part les victimes de ces pressions de
ces menaces qui sont totalement
intolérables et pour ressouder à la fois
la communauté enseignante à la fois la
hiérarchie de l'éducation nationale dans
les établissements scolaires parce que
ce qu'on constate malheureusement c'est
que bien souvent les victimes en tête
celles et ceux qui sont accusés à tort
l'islamophobie sont aujourd'hui lâché
que ce soit par leur administration ou
par leur collègue professeur julien audy
vous venez de d'évoquer la liberté
d'expression regardez ce qu'en pense
danièle obono de la france insoumise
justement elle cite également la liberté
d'expression ce qui menace la liberté
d'expression à l'université ce sont les
politiques autoritaires qui précarisent
stigmatise la recherche la sinistre
vidal d'une totale incompétence face à
la crise terni l'image de la france avec
sa chasse à l'islamo gauchisme
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez jeune
héros duda à danièle obono danièle obono
évidemment et dans le soutien c'est
l'avocate de c2c relais islamo-gauchiste
racialiste indigéniste au cas aucune
aucune surprise
moi je tiens à rappeler que c'est une
préoccupation aujourd'hui majeurs que la
liberté d'expression
évidemment qu'ils aient des
considérations sociales évidemment
qu'est la précarité des étudiants
aujourd'hui lié à la crise sanitaire
mais aujourd'hui des étudiants et je
dirais la société française dans son
ensemble est confronté malheureusement
un émiettement de la liberté
d'expression car aujourd'hui on voit
bien que quand on ose critiquer l'islam
qui n'est qu'une religion est donc en
droit français qui n'est qu'une opinion
dans le droit français
on peut détester une religion on peut
détester une opinion
politique idéologique on a tout à fait
le droit on n'a pas le droit de s'en
prendre aux croyants pour leur religion
ça c'est évidemment du racisme c'est
condamnable il faut le condamner avec la
plus grande fermeté
mais en france en tout cas dans notre
législation telles sont nos coutumes
telles sont nos règles de droit on peut
être islamophobe
on peut être cathophobes on peut être
judéophobe voilà ça il faut quand même
le rappeler et il faut sanctuariser ce
principe est là malheureusement
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'avec des
pressions avec des menaces et des
menaces qui conduisent quelquefois
jusqu'au pire jusqu'à des attentats ils
analysent comme l'a subi sa nouvelle
pâte il ya quelques mois comme les
persécutions comme évidemment le subit
actuellement
savez vous pardonnez moi il n'y a pas eu
d'avancée d'après faire ce samuel pâtit
c'est quand même un enseignant qui s'est
fait décapiter il n'ya et pourtant les
affaires continuent on n'a pas tiré les
enseignements de cette tragédie selon
vous malheureusement non visible non pas
tirer tirer les leçons de cette tragédie
qui était un traumatisme sans précédent
et qui aurait dû réveiller les pouvoirs
publics le gouvernement la société
française dans son ensemble
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous avons
un autre enseignant qui a dû renoncer
enseigne et qui aujourd'hui sous
protection policière qui est monsieur le
maire à trappes et nous avons la jeune
milla qui déscolarisent et parce qu'elle
a osé donc critiquer l'islam et on voit
bien qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures
parce qu'aujourd'hui les soi disant
victime d' islamophobie donc se disent
victimes parce qu'on leur interdit
d'aller à la piscine en burqini se
disent victimes parce qu'on leur
interdit de porter le voile intégral se
disent victimes
parce qu'elles n'ont pas du halal à la
cantine de leur école
voilà aujourd'hui mais il ya d'autres
victimes qui elles menacent sont menacés
sont persécutés tout simplement parce
qu'on les taxe de raciste ou simplement
parce qu'on les taxe d'islamophobe juste
parce qu'elles ont voulu comment
dirais-je assumer une opinion et assumer
la liberté d'expression confesseur
allemand en l'occurrence au coeur de
cette affaire à l'origine c'était un
d'un atelier informel de travail dit la
liberté d'expression lui fortement mener
c'est une minorité c'est d'imposer sa
loi y compris chez les enseignants
chercheurs on vous attaque de front si
vous osez dire quelque chose qui ne paie
pas en particulier sur ce qui concerne
l'islam c'est le tabou on imagine que
vous partagez cette opinion ce sera ma
dernière question
oui bien sûr on peut le constater le
déplorer malheureusement tous les jours
l'idéologie islamiste est un fascisme
c'est un fascisme qui condamne toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ne pensent pas
pareil
voilà et quand cette idéologie sous
couvert de lutter contre le racisme
avec ce concept que ce concept
totalement hypocrite d'islamophobie
empêchent les autres de penser empêche
les autres d'avoir une opinion
différente
évidemment que c'est extrêmement grave
et ça doit gérer un site et les plus
hauts responsables nos gouvernants à se
réveiller d'urgence
parce que cette idéologie l avance elle
avance surtout parce que l'état et la
république ne cesse de reculer
merci beaucoup julien en doublon
rappelle encore une fois que ça devait
être un débat avec un membre de
l'association action contre
l'islamophobie qui vous aurait donné la
réplique voilà qui s'est décommandé
quelques minutes avant ce face-à-face
merci avoue julien houde ou là